become so skilled so vigilant so
flat-out fantastic at what you do that
your talent cannot be dismissed only you
have the power to take responsibility to
move your life forward when you are
excellent you become unforgettable
people remember you you stand out need
motivation watch attend
what's up believe nation it's heaven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference in the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew in today's lessons from a
woman who grew up in poverty in rural
Mississippi to becoming the most
influential woman in the world and the
first multi billionaire black person in
the world
she's Oprah Winfrey and here's my take
on her top ten rules a success vol 4
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one master your craft and the number one
lesson I could offer you where your work
is concerned is this becomes so skilled
so vigilant so flat-out fantastic at
what you do that your talent cannot be
dismissed stop comparing yourself to
other people you're only on this planet
to be you not someone else's imitation
of you I had to learn that the hard way
on the air live anchoring the news one
night in my 20s when I first started
broadcasting I was 19 moved to an anchor
by the time I was 20 and I was just
pretending to be Barbara Walker
Walters I was just trying to talk like
Barbara act like Bravo Barbara hold my
legs like Barbara and I was on the air
and I hadn't read the copy fully and I
called Canada Canada and I did that on
the air I crack myself up because I
thought Barbara would never call Canada
Canada and that little breakthrough that
little crack that little moment that I
stopped pretending allowed the real me
to come through your life journey is
about learning to become more of who you
are and fulfilling the highest truest
expression of yourself as a human being
that's why you're here rule number two
my personal favorite find a way to serve
number two
you must find a way to serve Martin
Luther King said that not everybody can
be famous but everybody can be great
because greatness is determined by
service now we live in a world where
everybody wants to be famous and where
we admire people for just being famous
we think being known brings us value the
truth is all of that will fade in time
in three years you won't be able to name
the Housewives a banana the real truth
is that service and significance service
and the significance that you bring to
your service is that which is lasting so
to be able to whatever your occupation
or job or talent or gift is our honorees
today getting doctoral degrees -
apparently opposite fields HIV and AIDS
and the spoken word but what they have
in common is service using the spoken
word in service to community in the
world using your knowledge and
information about HIV and AIDS and
medicine in service to the world and if
you look at all the most successful
people in the world whether they know it
or not they have that paradigm of
service everybody's talking about Mark
Zuckerberg and IPO service jay-z rapping
service through the word to people
through song for many years I was really
just happy to be on TV and people would
stop and say oh you want TV yeah I'm on
TV I like being on TV it's a nice job
and it was about the time that I
received my honorary Doctorate from
Spelman around 1993 so I don't know if
that had something to do with it I
thought of myself as dr. Winfrey that I
went back and I took a long look at what
it was I was doing on on TV and made a
decision that I was no longer going to
just be on TV but I was going to use TV
as a platform as a force for good and
not be used by TV and I will tell you my
decision to make that significant change
in the way I operated on television
using television as a service changed my
career exponentially service through
medicine service through art using
whatever it is you produce your product
as a way of giving back to the world
when you shift the paradigm of whatever
it is you choose to do to service and
you bring significance to that success
will I promise you follow you service
and significance equals success that's
number two rule number three take
responsibility you are responsible for
your life and if you're sitting around
waiting on somebody to save you to fix
you to even help you you are wasting
your time
because only you have the power to take
responsibility to move your life forward
and the sooner you get that
the sooner your life gets into gear what
matters is now this moment and your
willingness to see this moment for what
it is accept it
forgive the past take responsibility and
move forward rule number four solve
problems you build the legacy not from
one thing but from everything I remember
when I just opened my school in 2007 I
came back and I had the great joy of
sitting in Maya Angelou stable she
hadn't been able to attend the opening
in South Africa and I said to her Oh
Maya the Oprah Winfrey Leadership
Academy that's gonna be my greatest
legacy I remember she was standing at
the counter making biscuits and she
turned she put the dough down and she
looked at me and she said you have no
idea what your legacy will be this
excuse me I just opened this school and
these girls and it's gonna be and she
said you have no idea what your legacy
will be because your legacy is every
life you touch every life you touch
that changed me and it's true you can't
personally stop anybody from walking
into a school with an assault rifle nor
can you single-handedly ensure that the
rights that your mother's and your
grandmother's fought so hard for will be
preserved for the daughters that you may
someday have and it'll take more than
you alone to pull 40 million Americans
out of poverty but who will you be if
you don't care enough to try and what
mountains could we move I think what
gridlock could we eradicate if we were
to join forces and work together and
service of something greater than
ourselves you know my deepest
satisfaction and my biggest rewards have
come from exactly that pick a problem
any problem and do something about it
because to somebody who's hurting
something is everything rule number five
always do the right thing always do the
right thing always
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
be excellent people notice think of how
you notice you go to Taco Bell somebody
gives you extra napkin and some sauce
you notice you want to go back to that
person cuz even at Taco Bell excellence
shows itself be excellent let excellence
be your brand
everybody talks about building a brand I
never even knew what that was when
people say you're a brand I would say no
I'm just Oprah what I recognized now is
that my choice to it every way in every
example in every experience to do the
right thing and the excellent thing is
what has created the brand years ago I
did an ad for Revlon for for an ad they
were doing called unforgettable women
and what I know is that when you are
excellent you become unforgettable
people remember you you stand out we got
us of what it is you become an
unforgettable woman and that is what we
all want we want to be unforgettable and
not forgettable so doing the right thing
even
when nobody knows you're doing the right
thing
we'll always bring the right thing to
you I promise you that why because the
third law of motion is always at work
for every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction that is so true in all
of our lives rule number six listen to
the universe the universe speaks to us
always first in whispers
[Music]
and a whisper usually in your life feels
like hmm
that's odd or hmm that doesn't make any
sense or hmm is that right it just
really feels like that it's that it's
that kind of subtle and if you don't pay
attention to the whisper it gets louder
and louder and louder and I say it's
like getting thumped upside the head you
don't pay attention to that
it's like getting a brick upside your
head you don't pay attention to that the
brick wall falls down that is the
pattern that I see in my life in so many
other people's lives and so I ask people
what are the whispers what's whispering
to you now and can you catch it in the
whisper rule number seven become
the-best-version-of-yourself
I have paid attention to my life because
I understand that my life just like your
life is always speaking to you where you
are in the language with the people with
the circumstances and experiences that
you can understand and interpret if you
are willing to see that always life God
is speaking to you now it took me a
while to actually really get this and to
understand it but once I did I started
paying attention to everything and one
of the reasons why I can now accept the
fact that I can offer my gatherings of
information and wisdom and call myself a
spiritual teacher is that every single
person who ever came on my show and I
hear there's like 37,000 guests I've
talked to a lot of them came from
dysfunction and a lot of them wouldn't
appear to be teachers but every one of
them had something to say that was
meaningful and valuable and that I could
use to grow myself into the best of
myself which is what all of our jobs are
your number-one job is to become more of
yourself and to grow yourself into the
best of yourself rule number eight
surround yourself with great people
people don't always like you and they're
not always happy for you and if you
surround yourself with people who are
not accustom to your success
they become fearful they become scared
because you are reflecting back
something to them but they don't
recognize now they're not going to say
you know I'm very fearful because you're
reflecting back to me something I don't
recognize they're going to say you know
what they're gonna say they're gonna say
who she thinks she is who's she thinks
she is that only happens when you were
around people who do not mean and want
and aspire to the best for you people
who want the best for you want you to be
your best so my greatest advice to you
is to surround yourself with people who
are going to fill your cup until your
cup runneth over so when people say
you're so full of yourself you can say
yeah
[Music]
yes I'm full I'm so full my cup runneth
over and to know that once your cup
runneth over
you cannot spend your life with your
gallon-sized offerings offering them to
pint-sized people you have got to
surround yourself with gallon-sized
people who can hang in the same company
with you so that you're not offering
your gallons to those little pipes out
there who can't hold it anyway rule
number nine
find your true passion if you can find
what is your passion if you find what
you love you never get tired or if you
do get tired if you you're fueled by the
energy of your work and you know what
you're supposed to do by how it feels
and so you know if you're doing the
right thing if it feels like it's right
to you and when you hit the thing that
feels right you know it's right because
it gives you your juice and you know
it's right because you would do it for
nothing you would do it for nothing and
find a way to be able just to do it in
order to be able to continue that's how
you know you're doing what you're
supposed to be doing and rule number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is have fun over your so
recognizable you ever able to sneak out
like disguise how do you ever come out
oh no I well the last time I had on a
hat and glasses somebody said to me well
you trying to be incognito but do I have
time for this really funny story sure so
I'm walking my dogs in Chicago and I
have my hair this is during the summer
several years ago my hair's cornrowed
and I'm walking and so there's this kind
of like homeless guy and I'm going past
the park and the guy goes how you doing
baby
[Applause]
what's your name so I ignored him
ignored him you know keep walking he
goes what you can't tell about your name
so I turned around and I said Oprah
Winfrey and he goes you wish
[Music]
I've got a really special bonus cut from
Oprah on how to rise that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know what did Oprah say that had
the biggest meaning to you what are you
going to apply immediately to your life
for your business leaving the comments
below when you write it down it's much
more likely to actually happen so put it
in the comments thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is
much love see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
you could use your gifts that's what
you're really here to do to illuminate
the darkness in our world so this is
what I also know that this this this
moment in time this is your time to rise
it is even though you can't go anywhere
you can't stand in line at Starbucks you
can't go to a party you can't go to any
place without everywhere you turn people
are talking about how bad things are how
terrible it is and this is what I know
the problem is everybody is meeting
hysteria with more hysteria and then we
just are all becoming hysterical and
it's getting worse what I've learned all
these years is that we're not supposed
to match it or even get locked in to
resisting or pushing against it we're
supposed to see this moment in time for
what it is we're supposed to see through
it and then transcend it that is how you
overcome hysteria and that is how you
overcome the sniping at one another the
trolling the mean-spirited partisanship
on both sides of the aisle the divisive
finess the injustice --is and the
out-and-out hatred you use it use this
moment to encourage you to embolden you
and to literally push you into the
rising of your life and to borrow a
phrase from my beloved mentor Maya
Angelou just like moons and like Suns
with the certainty of tides just like
the hopes springing high you will rise
if you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it won't you
believe it you act like I am Tulsa what
a wail out of a handcuffed lightning
throw Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I'm murder
rock into the stone hospitalized a brick
I'm so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 250 4 days of taking
action for a new habit to stick I've
created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access